gorgeous here in st louis it is
beautiful it's perfect time to take in a
double header a perfect time to see kk
go out there and make his fourth start
of the year he went five innings seven
hits one earned last time out against
the phillies
and he grips one the other way for a
basin pete's been doing more of that
lately going to right field and he's got
himself a one out single and that's what
he's been doing
so well the ball he's been
pulling has been the hanging breaking
ball
the 1-0
ground ball tommy edmond he's there
and the mets will strand a pair
half inning in the books here in game
one and there's no score
and there's marcus it'll be a sixth
start he's coming off his last start
he's really only had one bad start where
he let his emotions
get the best of him when the umpire
unplayed umpire kind of squeezed him but
he bounced back with a five-inning
performance and keep up the two unearned
runs hit them where they ain't home runs
cardinals have had a lot of those but
marcus strowman is hard to get up in the
air goldschmidt is one for three in his
career against this right-hander
and he smokes it one-nothing cardinals
oh
he almost broke the sign in left field
you can hear that up here
oh my goodness a frozen rope to left
you better cover up in big mac land dan
as
i was just saying it's all about the
long ball against marcus strowman my
goodness not waiting around gets himself
a fastball and puts a charge into this
bad boy
he's gonna be buying a new sign well he
did it he knocked out the lighting in
the d at big mac land
just a rocket off of big mac land
well it's gonna cost him a pretty penny
you know big mac lamb here's jonathan vr
switch hitter batting right-handed goes
for the first pitch one hopper deep
short the young long throw got him
good stretch by goldsmith and vr is out
6-3 paul was fading away toward the left
field foul line couldn't get as much on
the throw as he wanted but the throw was
right on target and really a brilliant
decision again you got to make it in a
in a very short period of time on how to
make that throw he was wondering i could
almost feel him thinking do i do a jump
throw do i plant and throw
oh two pitch
swinging a miss strike three high
fastball we've seen strowman go up top
with his fastball a little bit more this
year
and he blows tommy edmond away with a 92
mile an hour fastball it's the first
strikeout of the game from either team
by the way
find something to get you on
carlson out to right base hit
sinking liner third cardinal hit today
really good at best wasn't that bad
again just fighting stuff off fouling
off pitches until he got something that
he could drop the barrel on one and one
to count goldschmidt at the plate he hit
his sixth home run first played
appearance and he loops that one into
right field that might drop and it does
another blue pit for the cardinals with
carlson going first to third and the
redbirds not done here in the third
inning just put the ball in play and
good things happen
and that is what happened
with that that at-bat for paul
goldschmidt singling to right field and
with that ball going up in the sun
alonzo was holding at first base he
didn't see
where the ball
may possibly land he couldn't get to the
outfield grass mcneil the second baseman
couldn't get down the line so runners at
the corners extends the inning to nolan
aronado oronato is seven for his last 17
eight runs batted in in his last five
games the 0-1
base head into center
carlson will score goldsmith to third
two-nothing cardinals
and a two-out rally here for saint louis
you know with marcus strowman on the
mound you know you set your sights down
that's where he likes to live especially
against the right-handers this is
another sinker bottom of the zone
that swing is beautiful
1-1 polar hits this one toward left
that's looping toward the line arenado
can't reach it it's a base hit
bloop single for pilar conforto stops at
second the first two minutes are on here
in the top of the fourth runners on
first and second nobody out for mcneal
pilar was jammed and just kind of turned
on it quickly only an 88 mile an hour
fastball from kim
so even though it was right on the
wrists of pilar now the mets will have
the bases loaded and nobody out down two
nothing in the fourth inning of a seven
inning game
and james mccann will be coming up again
the 2-2 and mccann pulls that one on the
ground
drops it rolls over everybody saved how
about that the greatest third baseman in
the world was trying for a 5-5-3 double
play and he dropped the ball and the
mets get a run and the bases remain
loaded he's out he picked up the ball
with his foot on the bag so that's going
to be an out of third base
inside corner and he struck him out
first strikeout for kim
there have been three separate long
stops to this inning and kk is able to
dot this pitch on the inner half
another one-two pitch
he
struck him out
back-to-back case for kim
[Music]
3-2 fought off and
misplayed by alonso
was i saying about that sun field well
you said the right field yeah difficult
sun right now and he went straight into
defensive mode both hands up just
couldn't see it
strowman could use a strikeout here 0-2
to kisner
and he got him there's a big strikeout
for strowman now you got the pitcher do
up and he's being called back that's the
right and they're going to bat for kim
2-2 coming from strowman and he struck
him out
back-to-back strikeouts for strollman he
gets kids kisner and now carpenter and
now he's on the precipice of getting out
of trouble
struck him out strowman strikes out
three in a row and strands two in
scoring position
and carlson foul tips it for strike
three that's five strikeouts for stroman
including the last four hitters
knees in black from strowman and that's
five consecutive strikeouts for marcus
that was a little rembrandt right there
3-2
put in play by nolan aronado to short
lindor up with it
and save it first is nolan arnado
so it's an air on lindor and that's his
second this what happens when teams are
struggling a little bit little cracks
and all of a sudden you break make him
pay here from the stretch the pitch on
the way de young swings and it's a high
fly ball that goes deep left center
field to the track the wall it's gone
it's in the match bullpen a two-run
homer for paul de young
and the cardinals indeed add on and lead
four to one in the bottom of the fifth
and you can add to the mets unearned run
total with that swing of the bat by paul
de young his seventh home run he leads
the cardinals that one just barely
cleared
the left center field wall the jumping
left fielder kevin pillar the 2-0 pitch
round ball fairball goldsmith takes it
and the cardinals take game one of the
doubleheader